in our morning rounds would you ever
choose to stay awake during surgery some
specialty doctors offer patients the
opportunity to have local nerve blocks
instead of general anesthesia for
example this may happen in orthopedic
breast colon eye and cosmetic procedures
but not every patient may be suited to
this option for exhibit 8 our dr. David
agus is in Los Angeles
hey dr. David agus I saw this on an
episode of Grey's Anatomy the patient
was strumming the guitar and everything
I thought ah that's a TV show why would
anybody want to do this well in the case
of Grey's Anatomy you know when there's
a tumor in the brain you don't know
exactly where the motor section is of
the brain the the speech section and the
doctor does that so they can avoid
cutting things that are important but
there's a numeric rung around the
country that is people saying I want to
be in charge I want to be there when the
operation happens and at the same time
they're also saying you know I'm afraid
what if I don't wake up from anesthesia
it's cheaper they're less side effects
and this is a trend that's starting to
happen is that people be involved in
their own surgeries is it better for the
doctors I think it's difficult for the
doctors you know we're not trained in
medical school to have a two three-hour
conversation with a patient during a
procedure and watch what you say and if
you're gonna have trainees there you
know sometimes the patient doesn't want
the trainees and there's those
interactions that are sometimes
difficult to have when the patient's
awake at the same time it's a it's a
movement that we have to respect that
patients want but it's painful are they
cutting on you and you're awake that's
what I can't get over well it's a nerve
block okay you're blocking if you put a
regional block here you're not gonna
feel anything down or you know in the
hip they could do it and put a block you
know in your head you have a baby a
caesarean section is a great example
where they can actually do a spinal
block and you know you don't find
general anesthesia you also get a chance
to see what doctors talk about during
operation hey how does everything look
down there but there are some distinct
advantages dr. David agus no question
about it it's cheaper you can go home
quicker you know if you have operation
your hand you know with a regional you
can go home an hour to later versus
waiting a half a day for the general
anesthesia to wear off and having
somebody else drive you home you could
drive home yourself after this regional
so there's no question that the data are
showing that it may be better to do it
this way and who would be a good
candidate for this knee operations
extremity operations we're getting more
and more colonoscopies some people said
the doctor showed me my polyp during the
colonoscopy so it's a trend that's
happening and it's something to discuss
with your doctor if you're going to have
surgery and what happens if the patient
gets agitated or very frightened on the
table and has what they call a freak out
the technical term for that so if they
have a gale event these are always there
and anesthesiologist is always there and
a patient can be put under and they're
warned of that in advance if you get to
stress or there's a turn the operation I
may have to put you under so the key is
that communication prior to the surgery
so the patient knows what to expect okay
and what can happen Wow
it's a really interesting topic I think
so do it they're brilliant thank you
Madison is changing yeah always great to
talk to you thanks so much dr. David
agus yeah